the struggle is real  even for Justin Bieber beef stepped out  to buy some subway for himself and  Sophia Ricci and West Hollywood on  Wednesday when his credit card was  declined an employee at the store  confirmed the snafu to ET but fear not  Justin Bieber was in luck the employee  reveals that the customer behind him in  line  picked up the tab we're sure Bieber is  grateful for the favor but don't expect  a public thank you as his Instagram is  still inactive meanwhile the singer was  spotted jogging on a hiking trail in LA  Wednesday he ditched the shirt putting  his various tattoos on full display  instead Biebs either worked up his  subway appetite or he was burning off  the calories from his free lunch either  way he is trying to stay off the grid  you guys so enjoy the rest of your  summer JD